like if you took out the trash sometime
you're the boss for you and see that the
trash is getting over filling you just
grab it and take it out maybe in your
mind you think you'd be losing respect
but you actually wouldn't be at all in
fact everyone looks into those oh he's a
good guy
and you're working for me and you still
gotta maintain the discipline the more
that you treat them with respect or
didn't respect you they're gonna know
that you're not too high they're gonna
know that you're down to earth when I
was a teen commander Tashkent commander
I picked up brass I cleaned the ranges
with the boys I would recommend that
kind of absurd it didn't make people
think Oh Jacques
does not even better to do that actually
knew I had stuff to do but what I'm
gonna do they've got brass with the boys
ability relationships set the example
they'll respect you for it